welcome back to games sports coverage of
e3 2019 I'm Mike McCarty here with Lucy
James hey and also very pleased to be
joined by Sven from Larian studios hello
and Mike Murrells from Dungeons &
Dragons creative director over there
guys you had a pretty exciting
announcement this week I've been teasing
it a little bit on the site for a while
Baldur's Gate 3 arguably I think a lot
of people say one of the better RPG
Studios working today are tackling a
very beloved RPG franchise that must be
exciting for you guys to finally be able
to get it off your chest to everybody
I've been keeping it a secret for quite
some time already so I remember showing
you mines of Santa Fe which is like the
starter campaign of Dungeons and Dragons
with the game master mode of divinity 2
and back then we were already working on
the game so we reached out to these guys
when was it end of 2016
no sorry after original sin 1 if we
could license it and yeah I said maybe
we had long chats about it and then end
of 2016 they they told us come over here
we got something to propose to you and
they you still want to work on it and
the answer was yes now we're married
[Laughter]
it's funny baldur's gate I imagine like
everybody at Larian must have like grown
up or like it like play it a lot of
baldur's gate it must be like a dream
come true for them too they get to
tackle it you know why it was rather
interesting I had two groups and so we
have four studios and so I asked each
studio not to tell the other guys so
that I could have the pleasure of
announcing Bob's gate 3
and when I announced it to the first
figure I was instantly struck by like we
have a whole bunch of people that were
super excited because for all of them
balls gate was their first RPG or they
were very deep into Dungeons & Dragons
but then we also a group would never
heard of it
they never played it because they were
too young to actually have grown up when
it came out and so that was very
interesting
why now they've been completely
converted but I I didn't realize that
that was actually a thing that you
didn't know about those gates
yeah it was kind of this like pervasive
thing but there is a small subset of
people that don't know it but I guess
it's nice as well because the people who
aren't necessarily as familiar can now
revisit the older games and see how
they've inspired a ton of other recent
game
so that must be a kind of nice balance I
guess bringing to bold escape three
oh I think it's Dungeons and Dragons in
general is once people get into it they
get hooked so it's a very easy thing to
lead people into so I'm not worried
about the fact if they hadn't heard
about it this is going to be great
introduction to see RPGs and to Dungeons
and Dragons in general
Mike I'm assuming you've played where in
stuff what is it about Larian Studios
they're kind of like it's like oh
they're there the studio to make
Baldur's Gate three yeah I think what
we're looking for in a partner and what
I think Larian fits so well is being
able to tape the tabletop experience and
really bring it to a videogame and
really that sense of creativity in
gameplay that when you're making your
way through the world you get a sense
that when you run into an obstacle an
enemy or whatever it's up to the player
to decide how do I want to solve this it
there's not just pick a or B there's a
real sense of creativity of manipulating
the game system you've been given and
finding your own path board I remember
back when Baldur's Gate 1 first came out
I was so excited about it because I
could I was finally my chance to play
Dungeons and Dragons right now it's
always the dungeon master for my friends
so this idea of I can fire up this game
it feels like I'm hoping to get my
players handle to make my character and
then really truly enter the world of the
Forgotten Realms
and walk the streets of Baldur's Gate I
mean that to me that's what makes it so
exciting to really bring that open-ended
feel to a C RPG uh not only is it a feel
I mean you kind of you're taking
Dungeons & Dragons and you're taking I
guess the collective imagination of
well how do you kind of distill you know
the dungeons dragons mission the vision
of the thousands of actual players as
well as Larry Anne's vision and create a
game that will sort of appease everyone
in that way so this is a very easy
answer to that one we are using dungeon
dragon 6th edition and we're gonna be
Dungeon Master's here so we're making a
game based on everything that Mike and
his team has been creating and we're
gonna try to give you as much tools as
possible to have the adventure that you
create yeah it's almost like I imagine
making even like das - it was like you
are playing Dungeon Master just I'd say
a little bit like same amount of
imagination required but just a little
bit more technical know-how I don't know
if that's accurate to say the so one of
the things that's really cool about
dungeon and Dragons 5th edition is how
accessible it is so that is one of the
pillars that we took with us also in
making bulbs gate 3 it doesn't mean that
we're gonna simplify the gameplay on the
contrary but we're gonna make it very
easy to onboard people which is
something that they've done really well
and I think is one of the reasons for
the success of Dungeons & Dragons 5th
edition so when you're gonna start
playing you're going to be learning very
natural into learning systems systems
that are present but also system that we
put on top of it to capture what you do
at the table that you would otherwise
not be able to do in a video game and
then you'll start so around hold on a
minute can I do this and this oh that
works oh oh no that works you know and
then we have that that's where people
typically get hooked right is something
that we already brought to original sin
- you'll see a lot more of that in the
involves get trade it's easy for me to
look at divinity original sin - and then
say ok just take this game put it into
the dungeon dragons baldur's gate world
and that's that be a great game I
imagine you're doing more than that what
things are you doing to make this not
just dots to where the baldur's gate
skin there's a lot so first of all
there's the tonality and the visual
identity if you see the teaser trailer
it's very different
already than original sin - but -
different maybe if you weren't warned
about what was inside of it so there's
that then you obviously have fifth
edition rule set so it's not glasses
this time it's cost based so that makes
a very big difference and how you
approach the gameplay how you approach
party composition because in our
originals
you could do whatever you want is
essentially with each character and then
we learned a lot when we were making
original Center and we had the systems
based approach where we want to give you
this toy set that you can fool around
with to overcome whatever challenges we
throw at you here we are trying to go
much broader than that so we're making a
game of pretty much similar lengths as
original sin - but you just get more
options at every single opportunity
inside of the game so the I can't really
elaborate on it but I one example I've
been using is when Mike is going to be
dungeon mastering a campaign with you
which is awesome by the way he is going
to end his descriptions with what do you
do all right and then we're gonna figure
out what we're gonna do and look at our
process or whatever we have and video
game is limited by what can you do
what are the options that you're gonna
get inside of all the video game and so
or or quest and making this game
literally is how can we maximize the
things that you can do it's pretty
baffling to hear you say that because
divinity original sin - if I had to
point to a game that lets you do almost
anything it's that how do you do more
than I know it's a loaded question but
how do you allow the player to do more
than divinity original sin to allows
it's so one of the things that we've so
we go through the entire player handbook
alright then we figure out how can we
port things into the game and then we go
through a whole bunch of other things
also and so we pour this well if you do
this we have to sustain it throughout
the entire game when you look what's in
that play your handbook there's some
pretty crazy [ __ ] in there alright and
so we are automatically when you start
thinking about it well if you put that
in a game that means that and that is
going to be possible will be allowed it
and typically we try to answer yes
so probably we say too much yes and not
enough no but that as a result of that
you're starting to see really I am
thinking of an example right now I will
show it so I'm not going to talk about
it but it is really really cool and it
is based just on a discussion like if we
allow this you should be able to do this
and should be able to do this and then a
tabletop campaign Mike would say well
okay yeah sure do a strength check and
that's but we have to put an entire
system around it to be able to do that
when you're tackling the lore of
Dungeons and Dragons I mean how
to you being on yourselves to keep
completely true to the source material
and who are the people at the studio her
kind of keeping all that in check and I
like to think there's like a law master
sat in the corner or we have these guys
put him in the flask yeah I've spent a
lot of time trapped in an iron flask
giving an advice for really what it
comes down to is the a lot of my role
and the role my team plays is really
collaborating we don't really think of
it as like that where the more police
that we kind of step in and say no
you're having too much fun right or
anything you know what we want to do is
think about what are the big picture
elements of Dungeons & Dragons bothers
gated themes the key characters and then
find ways to bring them forward a lot of
times like Sven and his team will come
to us and say hey we have an idea to do
like a storyline like this and then
we'll start what will supply like well
here's a character that might be
involved in that or that sounds exactly
like the kind of plan like this type of
monster might be up to
and then Larian goes off and starts
building the specific character and the
environment that goes with that a lot of
it is like working with a dungeon master
could just give them the support they
need to tell the stories that they want
to to present to their players just in
this case they're talking about like
millions of cliff is rather than just
your group of five at the table but for
us Dungeons and Dragons the lore is
really there to inspire stories it's not
about building barriers or telling you
like oh you can't go that way or you
can't do this it's a jumping-off point
yeah the example I like to use is like
Andy Andy orcs are like these you know
bloodthirsty Marauders but you could
still find an orc who's a wizard that's
still possible but what's important to
us is well what's the story of that
character how did this orc go from being
a marauding warrior to now studying
magic candlekeep
or whatever whatever it is and I think
that's what makes TNT fun is you learn
the baseline of what the lore is but
then you meet specific exceptions to
that rule but then have their stories
that you can then explore and mess with
in the game the thing that was always
separated tabletop and I mean always the
thing that separated tape laughs RPGs
from video games is like tabletop you do
as long as you can imagine and you have
a DM who knows decently well what
they're doing you can do that with games
that was not always case that still it's
not the case
so tackling that concept and trying to
put it into a game which I do think das2
is
the closest we've gotten you kind of
mentioned maybe we are saying yes too
much I imagine there must be a genuine
worry like what will you say what if
this what if that becomes literally
infinite branches that you could go into
I imagine that must be pretty daunting
for the team well we went through player
handbook and we coded things and we
essentially have green orange threats so
green straight port no problem it's
gonna be easy orange we need to modify
it's not gonna work in the video game
for whatever reason red no fur no way so
the easiest example that I've been using
is the witch spell alright so I can pop
up a dialog and what do you wish for and
then I can script all of that stuff but
you'll never gonna be able to capture
what you can do with a witch spell in a
campaign so there are things that you
can't port but there's a lot of stuff
that you can put in there and there's a
lot of stuff actually that that not
necessarily has been done in C RPGs
before that you can put in there and
that makes some of these things liable
right it's much harder of course if the
for instance we do come up with
illusions there's so many things that
that could be so that we will never be
able to do but maybe there's some subset
of that that we can take and put in the
video game and allow give that to you as
a tool to use to distract people what's
the ratio like green to orange to red
when you looked at it I don't know the
number but it's pretty large the green
and the orange ones
there's no I there's a couple of zones
where it's very red but it's there's
quite a lot in there you'll be surprised
by how much we actually put in I think I
hope if I had I guess there's question
for both of you
what makes Baldur's Gate Baldur's Gate
like you coming back to it from a design
perspective and you just kind of like
from the Dungeons & Dragons perspective
if I haven't played Baldur's Gate 1 or 2
what what can I expect all right
you wanna start well I should I have a
convenient answer to that if you're
looking to you hop back into the bolts
of gate series or you're looking for an
instruction to the world of Aldersgate
conveniently enough on September 17th
we're releasing a tabletop role-playing
game product called Baldur's Gate
descent into a furnace and it basically
provides an update it's been about 100
years since the events the baldur's gate
- so in this book we go over the history
of Baldur's Gate the locations in town
the prominent characters who live there
and we also provide to complete levels
one
13 tabletop campaign you can play
through let's experience baldur's gate
firsthand because for us baldur's gate
it's one big story regardless of whether
you're playing a video game or the
tabletop game it's all one location it's
all one epic saga and so for us we
started building this campaign based on
murders and ballers gates because we I'm
gonna say it clips again balls get
descent into a furnace didn't exist back
then and we worked closely together with
the lead writer on that Adam Lee and
what we're gonna bring you is a story
that is starting outside of the city
that is about the city but that's
dominantly about your party and it's
going to go beyond the city also over
the past few years I mean there seems to
be after this explosion in you know fan
love for Larian studios and also kind of
with this huge resurgence of dungeons
dragons they are appearing in things
like stranger things you know I think on
my Twitter timeline every Sunday people
are just talking about they're playing
Dungeons & Dragons over Skype with
people I mean both of you like what's
that been like and kind of being in the
thick of those worlds and you know
seeing how much people love those
dragons and Larian games online well I
think it feels fantastic
cuz I've been a tabletop role-playing
game fan since I was a little kid it's
not six right and I played all the
classic computer role-playing games like
wizardry and bard's tale back in the day
so for me I love role-playing games and
to see people getting back into them
just gets me so excited because it's
like this to me like I mean I kind of
have you know a little bit of a maybe
perspective on things a bit different
but I think roleplay games are the best
games ever right and so to see people
playing them gets me so excited like I
just and especially the diverse group of
people coming into the right people who
maybe otherwise never would have thought
they were playing would be into
role-playing games or now getting into
them because I think games like you know
I think roll the game is getting more
and more accessible right I know that's
something you've talked about you know
making thinking of Baldur's Gate 3 is a
chance to grow the role-playing game
audience even more I was just gonna say
I think that you mentioned fifth edition
is the most accessible version of
Dungeons & Dragons RPG games video games
can be super daunting to get into if you
don't know what you're doing or even if
you do know what you're doing especially
in a game like divinity original sin or
presumably like Baldur's Gate 3 that
lets you do all
these different things are you making
steps to make baldur's gate 3 accessible
to people who might not be hardcore RPG
players so I got a I got several altars
to that so I don't know how much time I
have it I'll try to cover yeah so
there's this interesting thing we go to
pretty much every single packs here in
the US and so we put original sin 2
there and we put the people on the bench
and they can play together and almost
continuously you see friends coming over
with another friend and say you should
try this let's try it out and then
typically that converts into a cell so
the biggest and the hardest problem is
getting people to try it out all right
once they try it out it's not very
complicated and dungeon drags is really
not very complicated you know you in if
you take original sin - you got a couple
of action points you have a bunch of
actions they're reacting the way that
you would expect it it's turn-based you
don't have to be fast-paced and you have
to select I like options and then you
have to explore and that's it that's the
formula and so obviously there's UI
things that we can improve but in
general people get it and once they get
it and then they figure out they can
play it with their body that's typically
wondered when they're off and so with
Bob's get tree we will take what we
learned in terms of onboarding terms of
UI and teaching people maybe not having
it too hard initially but letting them
roll into it but having that same manner
of explaining to them this is what the
game is is what you do use your
imagination as works right if we can get
that and we can bring it to them in a UI
that is comprehensible and we can make
it to them clear to them that the player
agency is going to be rewarded
continuously I think you will see a lot
of people picking it up awesome Sven and
Mike thank you both so much for coming
out of the stage this is probably my one
of my favorite excitements of the show
I'm looking forward to baldur's gate 3
more people should play toss to if they
haven't we really appreciate it we are
gonna be right back after this with
warframe so stick around
[Music]
[Applause]